bonjour Bruce c'est Bill Gates eh bien c'est
fou pour moi que tu aies 50 fois plus de
risques de mourir si tu es né en Afrique
que si tu es né dans un pays riche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Londyn j'avais voyagé  en Afrique et nous
avons été surpris de voir à quoi ressemblaient les conditions dans
les pays pauvres, puis nous avons
commencé à lire sur la santé et nous avons été
choqués de constater que plus d'un million d'
enfants mouraient du paludisme chaque
année des enfants meurent de diarrhée même
s'il existait un vaccin  être utilisé dans
des pays plus riches qui pourraient empêcher cela
et nous avons donc réalisé que c'était une
injustice incroyable et nous devrions donc nous unir
à d'autres personnes pour faire progresser la
santé mondiale et sauver des vies, nous avons la chance
d'avoir la richesse créée par
le succès de Microsoft  ainsi que le
soutien que Warren Buffett a fourni
grâce à son succès commercial et la
question était donc de savoir comment pourrions-nous prendre cet
argent et le redonner au monde pour
aider ceux qui en ont le plus besoin à sauver des vies à
améliorer la vie en t  la meilleure façon possible
eh bien notre fondation a la santé mondiale est
essentiellement sa plus grande priorité, mais
il y a deux parties dont l'une est des choses
comme le Fonds mondial ou le fonds pour les vaccins
qui achètent en fait les outils dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui et les fournissent à tous ceux qui en ont
besoin que nous finançons également  beaucoup de science,
nous nous attendons à ce que les scientifiques soient capables
de créer un vaccin contre le VIH et ainsi nous pourrons
enfin empêcher les gens d'être
infectés et ensuite nous n'aurons que les
personnes qui ont déjà été infectées afin que
nous mettions des milliards dans la partie scientifique que nous
mettre des milliards dans la partie accouchement c'est
surtout les maladies infectieuses nous devrions
pouvoir réduire cela de façon spectaculaire nous avons en
fait réduit le nombre de décès d'enfants nous l'avons réduit
de moitié nous avons réduit les décès dus au VIH les décès dus au
paludisme les décès dus à la tuberculose et c'est pourquoi
c'est si excitant  ce mouvement
travaille le gouvernement au nom de
leurs contribuables les scientifiques les
travailleurs sur le terrain ils devraient
célébrer qu'il s'agit d'une
justice améliorée et d'un excellent travail w  Nous avons besoin de beaucoup
d'innovation, mais si nous voulons
arriver à zéro, il n'est pas facile d'
éradiquer une maladie, le monde est fermé
à la poliomyélite
et c'est l'objectif final de se débarrasser de
toutes ces maladies infectieuses qui
créent cette incroyable santé.  iniquité
[Musique]
toi